there's no saying God may have made the
world but the Dutch made the Netherlands
this is the Maslin barrier and it's one
part of the Delta works a set of mega
structures that hold back the ocean when
high seas threatened of love this
country this is one of the world's
largest movable structures a pair of 210
metre long gates designed to seal off
the main shipping route to rough down
port and hold back storm surges
depending on whose measurements you
believe somewhere between a fifth and a
third of the Netherlands sits below sea
level
a lot of that reclaimed from the ocean
over years through managing marshland
and moving earth and pumping water there
are areas of the Netherlands described
as former islands and these gates are
part of the enormous system the Dutch
engineers built to keep this country dry
and a couple of hours northeast of here
is where they learn to do it this is
just one part of the ten square
kilometers of vanta log Voss and it was
built when the only way to simulate
water was to use water it's now a
National Monument and nature is taking
back these structures these experiments
what the loop means how the flow runs
through a system that is water loop in
dirt over here mostly done what we call
model studies so basically simulating
nature at the certain smaller scale the
whole area started more or less after
the Second World War so around 1950 when
there was a big demand for model studies
related to the Delta Works in the
southwest part of the Netherlands it was
for the Delta Works but we also did many
studies all over the world the finish of
the harbor of Libya harbors in Tunisia
harbours in in the Far East of Hong Kong
the main reason for building the Battle
of boss here is that we needed a lot of
space for the models because around 1950
all the models will outdoor and another
thing is you need water where we are
standing here is basically the bottom of
the former Saudi sea so we are here
standing at the level let's say minus 2
or minus 3 meters below mean sea level
here we have a natural water drop of
about 5 meters so we just have to open
the gate at that part of the route and
the water will flow freely through this
area
we are standing in what we call the
Delta flume an enormous rectangular box
so to say and now you see more than
artist's impression of this flume with
certain section cut out and placed
perpendicular to the original flume wall
in this flume the studies are related to
the design of breakwaters
these breakwaters are enormously costly
in the order of let's say 100 million
euros you take a section out of your
breakwater and then scale it down to
about one to five and test it to you
I've been in meetings where they fight
for every centimeter of the block well
if we propose now let's say that the
block should be one meter they are
scooting out to be the block ninety five
centimeters a ninety six centimeter and
ninety seven centimeter because that is
money it's centimeter you can't use on
the block is money and therefore this
was one of the cash cows of Delta Daleks
doing these sturdy bits are expensive
but still cheap in the design of a big
breakwater at the moment of Battle of
boss is a kind of tourist attraction the
upcoming of the computer that one of the
main reasons that this area was left
around 2000 we do excursions for
tourists to see how we operated the old
outdoor models and this room is handed
over to the natural monument
organization about two years ago so
although we left the territory in 2000
this room was still operational for
about 50 years because you cannot easily
replace this room to another place the
Water Act part of Dutch law requires the
government to maintain flood defences
and it establishes a maximum risk that's
allowed so there are parts of the
Netherlands that in law it must take a
one in ten thousand year weather event
to flood the trouble is that the
predictions for what one in ten thousand
years involves keep getting worse since
they were completed in 1997 the gates of
the Maslin barrier have only been closed
in defense twice but that's going to
become more common in future flood
defenses that were researched here were
designed to protect the cities and towns
that people already lived in but with
those defenses in place people kept
building and the consequences of failure
keep growing the
are going to have to keep making the
Netherlands for a long time yet